elle aura marqué de son empreinte la
monarchie britannique
elle laisse aussi deux fils william 25
ans aujourd'hui et harry 22 ans ils ont
pris dans le coeur des anglais autant de
place désormais que leur père le prince
charles
évocation signé maryse burgot will i am
a 15 ans son frère harry 12
ses deux enfants viennent de perdre leur
mère il leur faut pourtant accepté cette
apparition publique devant le palais de
buckingham
les sujets de sa majesté réclament leur
présent votre mère vivra à jamais à
travers votre regard
aujourd'hui ces deux princes sont
devenus des hommes
et évidemment il n'évoque publiquement
que les jours heureux
nous avons eu tant de chance d'avoir une
telle mère il ne se passe pas une seule
journée sans que nous ressentions son
absence et son influence
elle était vraiment un exemple pour nous
de suivre aux elle était très
attentionné bien sûr c'est notre mère
c'est donc normal que nous disions cela
elle était tellement affectueuse et 12e
elle nous manque et nous bien sûr qu'à
bien d'autres encore plus haut
car la princesse de galles fut une mère
rieuse très présente et soucieuse de
sortir ses enfants du cocon de la
famille royale
même si évidemment la presse n'était
jamais loin
les naissances les premiers pas les
inscriptions dans les écoles les plus
huppés les moindres partie de pêche avec
le prince charles
rien de leur enfance puis de leur
adolescence ne semble échapper aux
photographes
cette pression médiatique n'empêche pas
william de grandir sagement il est le
plus beau parti de grande bretagne a rit
beaucoup moins consensuelle fait la une
des médias pour s'être déguisé en
officier nazi et il se bat de temps en
temps avec les photographes à la sortie
des boîtes de nuit
une mère c'est impossible a remplacé
bien sûr que le prince charles a fait de
son mieux mais qui mieux qu'une mère
peut vous dire qu'on vous fait une
bêtise
à 19 ans harry se rachète une conduite
dans un orphelinat du lesotho en afrique
il semble suivre les traces de sa mère
et l'enfant terrible de la famille
royale trouve enfin sa voie
chez les militaires
diplômé de l'académie de sanders le
jeune officier veut aller combattre en
irak
c'est sûr ne me laisse pas aller sur le
fond je ne resterai pas assis là à me
morfondre
mais harry est rattrapé par son
étiquette princière pour des raisons de
sécurité il n'est pas autorisé à partir
en ira williams lui aussi a dû se
résoudre à accepter son destin
un jour ce diplômé de géographie torrent
roi au moins lui les strates ont la
liberté de choisir son épouse sa romance
avec kate middleton rencontrés à
l'université passionne d'ailleurs les
britanniques sont ils séparés sont ils
toujours ensemble mystère elle est en
tout cas poursuivie par les paparazzi
comme le fut autrefois lady diana